et on va faire un point people il y a
Harry et Méane qui faut encore parler
d'eux les deux tourturons ont quitté
l'Angleterre en 2020 pour s'installer au
Canada puis en Californie pour échapper
à la pression médatique des PAP paradis
il pensaient avoir pouvoir élever leurs
enfants dans un cadre paisible et
sécurisé seulement ils ne peuvent plus
bénéficier d'un système de sécurité
adéquate aux États-Unis mais également
au Royaume-Uni ils sont dans une merde
noir har c'est comme ça qu'il disent
làbas il non ils sont en bullshit total
ils sont vraiment ils sont dans la dem
de ouf
voilà donc je lesembrasse d'ailleurs har
megéan Markel donc on va en parler et ah
il y a Miriam qui vient je savais pas
aller là oh aller là génial ça va toi ça
va tuas vu ce que j'ai dit sur toi tu as
vu ce que j'ai dit sur toi NONAH tant
pis tu regardes pas
l'émission à chaque fois qu'il revient
dans son pays seul ou en famille Harry
se sent en danger depuis qu'il n'est
plus membre actif de la famille royale
le prince n'a plus droit à la protection
des policiers de façon systématique il
arrive qu'ils doivent payer des gardes
du corps privé la protection de la
famille royale est payée par les
contribuables Harry le sait il a même
proposé de prendre ses frais à sa charge
ce qui lui a été refusé d'où ce recours
devant la Haute Cour de Londres c'est
[Rires]
ma
monte
bonsoir il se passe quoi avec Harry et
Méan alors vous comme vous l'avez dit
tout à
l'heure quoi vas-y vas-y t'emde pas
j'y vais moi je trace tant pis rigolez
allez-y c'est pas
souci donc Harry et Mégan depuis depuis
le le le mexite n'ont plus les mêmes
avantages qu'avant puisqu'ils ne font
plus partie de la royauté et du coup
tout ce qui est vas-y vas-y continue
fais tout ce qui est prise en charge
leur sécurité n'est plus prise par par
l'État et du coup Harry a tenté un
procès au ministère de l'Intérieur de de
l'Angleterre parce qu'il estime yes
parce qu'il estime que sa sécurité quand
il vient au Royaume-Uni est en danger et
en plus pour cause ça coûte extrêmement
cher donc il y a eu un procès qui a été
ouvert la semaine dernière qui s'est
déroulé à H cl qui s'est déroulé à H cl
de G j'ai rien fait franchement c'est
insupportable c'est pas moi c'est toi ça
va non mais c'était sympa ouais ouais
non vas-y vas-y non cé sympa donc c'est
un procès qui s'est déroulé à huclos
dans dans dans laquelle les les les
avocats de dans lequel pardon les
avocats de de de Harry ont essayé de de
plaider en sa faveur afin que l'État
finance sa sécurité lorsqu'il vient aux
États-Unis alors là Harry a sorti le
grand jeu il est pas venu hein sur place
mais mais il a envoyé une lettre que qui
a été lu en disant que lui et ses et ses
enfants et sa femme étaient en danger
lorsqu'il venait au Royaume-Uni que vu
ce qu'il avait vécu avec sa maman alors
ils ont acheté une une villa montéito
non oui montéito en Californie alors
j'ai les photos de la Villa 10 bares 10
million d'euros regardez la Villa
franchement euh à voir elle est très
belle très très belle la V regardez non
franchement la V est très belle regardez
j'ai une autre photo regardez une autre
photo très beau ah c'est beau he 10
million j par rapport à celle de Johnny
pour le même prix 10 millions d'euros je
pruxfère 100 fois ou à 10 je te les
demain arrête un peu Michel il s'est
barré avec ah voilà quand même ah ouais
il y a il y a le médecin qui s barré
avec ton portable bon bah tu le prendras
tout à l'heure ok c'est très beau là
leur maison ça rien à voir avec mon
sujet mais bon c'est pas grave mais mais
mais le truc c'est que quoi mais en fait
leur sécurité coûte chaque année
200lion8 d'euros ce qui est éorme et
c'est vrai que c'est c'est assez
embêtant pour Harry parce que en plus de
ça il est extrêmement menacé depuis
qu'il a écrit son son bouquin le
suppléant où il dit qu'il a tué 25
talibans en fait il a il a vraiment une
épée d'amocla sur la tête parce que les
talibans qui sontevenus au pouvoir le le
cible en disant qu'ils veulent que voilà
il passe pour la Cour Pénale
international de crime contre de crime
de guerre il y a même Al-Qaïda qui est
contre lui et qui lui a mis une cible
sur la tête donc ça ça il est vraiment
vraiment en danger merci euh
merciam j'ai décroché sur Harry Megam
j'en ai rien à Carry euh vous avez vu
queil y a secret Story qui revient TF1
vient diffuser la toute première bande
d'annonce pour le grand retour de
l'émission et on va revenir sur Secret
Story ça revient le gasting est en cours
sachez-le puisque j'ai eu les les infos
ça va reprendre et on va rappeler Secret
Story rappelez-vous à l'époque il y
avait beaucoup de clash dans Secret
Story
regardez ici bien
tuis r tu
fais je refais qui je refais Leila là
Leila ok alors maintenant tu me lâ et
ton tu te mets dans ton essaie pas de
faire ton buzz avec moi s'il te plaît
moi essaie faire mon buz qui elle me
respecte pas de sa tête jusqu'à ses
de pied elle me respecte pas du
haut de 1 M70 elle ne me respecte pas il
y a une vitre heureusement va te faire
soigner ne me dis pas ça parce que moi
moi aussi je vais te faire soigner toute
seule d'accord je vais t'emmener te
faire soigner donc me dis pas va te
faire soigner la Sorci d'accord AC
que tu vas me rendre dans le cul je te
rentrer mon point dans le cul tu vas
voir qui si tu rapportes des trucs
rapportles correctement au moins
d'accord ouais rapportles correctement
et m-toi de ce qui te regarde
caméra alors et c'est vrai qu' on sait
on se remet les petits extraits Gilles
ça va revenir donc c'est rest stor assez
vite oui oui c'est sûr maintenant ça va
revenir alors après tout dépend du
casting parce qu'il faut que ce soit un
casting qui soit à la fois un peu trash
pour aller très loin et en même temps
réel donc est-ce qu'ils vont trouver
l'équilibre je suis pas sûr
franchement il y a pour moi est-ce que
c'est pas une émission datée est-ce que
ça va plaire aux jeunes est-ce qu'il a
encore un public ça me parait Inc alors
il y avait vous a fait compiles aussi
des perles de Secret Story
regardez je oigé de faire je suis
quelqu'un qui est très intérioriste
c'est vraiment le ying et le Young entre
nous deux donc voilà on se complète
redescende pied dessous je pense que
maximès très
al moi je pe Allis me faire enaou quoi
mais un petit peu angoisseuse hein à
s'apportter de de la joie dans la maison
du du l'évadement tout
simplement et euh C story elle avait été
écrit en 2007 cette émission elle a été
arrêtée en 2017 10 ans après sa création
et 2 ans après son transfert sur TFX qui
était NT1 à l'époque il y a des extraits
voilà cultes moi un de mes extraits
cultes c'était le secret le je vous
l'avais montré la dernière fois le
secret le plus court de l'histoire c'est
quand Rachel lein Trapani avait fait son
entrée dans la maison et c'était un truc
de ouf c'est vraiment le secret n'a pas
tenu 2 secondes
regardez moi je pense que ça va être
court voilà Amélie depuis notre
rencontre tu m'as réappris à aimer tu me
fais découvrir les joies de l'amour et
du bonheur mon soit le plus cher serait
de te garder à mes côtés jusqu'à la fin
de mes jours pour faire de toi la femme
la plus heureuse tu dit que tu veux
quitter non tout ce que je t'ai dit je
t'ai dit à toi ça t'a ça t'a attends
est-ce que je suis une F bien ça t'a
blessé parce que tu sais comment je suis
qu'il faut que je te dise tout c'est pas
pour ça que je t'ai dit que je te laisse
tomber et que tu veux plus te voir plus
te parler loin de là je pense que j'ai
trouvé la plus belle femme que je puisse
avoir ça fait voilà c'est partage tout
le même moment avec moi ah je 24
ensemble tous les jours toujours
ensemble alors des bébés ça c'était il
se sont trop c'était la compile des
histoires d'amour mais on va revenir sur
l'extrait de Rachel le grain trapaniier
regardez on l'a pas du coup des génies
j'espère que vous avez Sabrina le micro
oui on l' et bravo vous êtes des gées
surtout que c'est bien merci allezy
quand à Sabrina le micro lui donne envie
de prendre son pied la perchette vers
toi en la prenant par le
pied non pas avec le pied par le pied de
la perchette par le pied voilà mais
non voilà d'ù l'expression de popier bon
œil et alors vous avez vu aussi en
histoire aussi c'était pas mieux hein
regardez ça vous rappel ça d'Eddy
regardez ici la voix Eddie ne bouge pas
qui a peint La
Joconde 5 Christ Willem je
pas Léonard de V ah
ouais
et enfin pour le plaisir est-ce que vous
voulez revoir Benjamin
Castaldi toujours un bonheur parce qu'on
ne sait pas qui va présenter C
story Benjam Benjam c'est pas Benjamin
SRE chose à on parle même de Nabil mais
ouais on parle de
Nabil ce sera peut-être mieux on parle
de Nabila mais voilà pour présenter je
sais pas peut-être la quotidienne ou on
parle de enfin il y a des noms qui
circule je vous le
dirai les gens critiquent parce que NAB
pas fait Secret Story donc part des
gensellea pas de légitimité à faire à
faire ce progam moi j'ai jamais été chez
le coiffeur c'est pas pour ça que je me
coiffe
pase bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur
TF1 ça y est ça y est c'est ce soir
c'est maintenant le lancement de
l'événement de TF Secret
Story après toutes les plus folles
rumeurs entendu élu vous serez toute la
vérité rien que la vérité ce soir je
vous le jure vous connaîtrez enfin les
13 candidats si filles SEP garçons qui
vont vivre dans une maison de 900 m² et
surveillé 22h sur 24 par 50 caméras et
autant de
micro
alors je l dis c'est ni Nabila ni Benji
ah voilà ouais normalement c'est que
c'est voilà normalement c'est
normalement la Ji voudrait que ce soit
Christophe beugrand et lui il veut
heinrocher cibal aussi on parle aussi de
camibal je crois pas je crois qu'on
c'est plus plus enfin il parî Cara pron
le directeur des programmes change
d'avis tous les jours il changeait moins
d'avis quand il était avec moi parce que
c'est moi qui lui disait quoi faire euh
voilà bah il faut dire la vérité mais
oui je me marre oui si je dis la vérité
j'ai rien à allez j'ai plus moi
j'ai plus rien à perdre je m'en fous moi
allez rappelez-vous le 28 octobre on
apprenait la mort de Matthieu Perry
chandleur dans friend et l'acteur avait
été retrouvé inanimé dans son jacuzzi
des antidépresseurs et des anxiolitiques
avaient été retrouvé dans la maison de
l'acteur aujourd'hui Jennifer Aniston
fait de nouvelle révélation concernant
matthieew Perry alors elle a donné une
interview au magazine Variety et et
là-dedans elle a elle elle annonce que
le matin même de de sa mort elle échanga
avec lui par texto et qu'il allait super
bien c'était un homme heureux qui avait
envie de voilà de de de qui était en
quête de de bonne santé de bien-être il
avait même arrêté arrêté de de de fumer
et donc au moment où elle elle elle
échangeait avec lui par il était super
heureux il rigolait ensemble et cetera
donc elle ne comprend elle ne croit pas
à l'hypothèse du du du suicide ou même
d'une noverdose médicamenteuse c'est ça
exactement